after analyzing and rewatching one piece
for hundreds of hours I noticed 13
things that don't make any sense for
example we know that one piece
characters come in all shapes and sizes
but did you know that those sizes are
changing every other Arc think back to
Luffy's flashback when lucky Ru shoots
the Bandit in this scene Ru is clearly
shorter than Shanks and his height is
probably around 5 ft however fast
forward to the Marine Ford Arc and he
has somehow grown to over 8 ft being
significantly taller than his C it
another great example of this is zoro's
new sword enma you see when Odin and
Zoro wield this sword everything seems
to be normal right well yeah until you
realize that Odin is actually over two
times bigger than Zoro with this in mind
enma should be gigantic when held by
Zoro but for some reason it isn't does
Emma just shrink and expand to suit the
user let's finish this part with
something fun what do you think is the
height difference between Roger and rley
think carefully believe it or not
there's actually a 3T height difference
between them this is only the first out
of 13 plot holes we are covering today
and the last one will completely blow
your mind all right so back in alabasta
a certain someone made an interesting
statement after using his bird bird
fruit model Hawk pel declared that there
are only five flying devil fruits in
existence although this seemed realistic
during the early one piece it quickly
became nonsense as there are way more
devil fruits that Grant flight if you
count pel's Hawk maros Phoenix kaido's
Dragon King's trodan and Le's angelic
Wings it's already five fruits but
there's more of course for example Bion
from the tonata kingdom has the bugb
fruit model Hornet and kabo has the
model rhinoceros beetle both of these
obviously Grant users the ability to fly
moving on how about Buffalo from Don
Cote Pirates and his spin spin fruit it
literally creates propellers around the
user and gives them the ability to fly
since Shiki is also a confirmed Cannon
character we can also count his float
float fruit which as the name suggests
is all about flying and making things
float I'd say this is more than enough
evidence to debunk this statement it's
most likely that at one point Odo really
wanted there to be only five flying
devil fruits but ditch the idea later on
another thing that makes zero sense is
how only 7% of people watching this
channel are subscribed I mean seriously
guys click the Subscribe button to fix
this it's absurd anyway you remember how
Viv was a member of Baroque works and
worked under crocodile during the
alabaster Arc at first you may think
there's nothing unusual with this but I
just have to ask how the hell didn't
crocodile recognize her you can argue
that he doesn't know the face of
everyone who works under him and
although that's true he must have known
what Viv looks like considering she was
one of the key members she didn't even
wear the mask or disguise herself in any
way are we really supposed to believe
that crocodile who had all kinds of
information about the royal family and
had lived in Alabaster for over 10 years
didn't know what the princess of the
Kingdom looked like not only that but
how is it possible that in the whole
Baroque Works which has over 2,000
members nobody noticed that the actual
princess is fighting alongside them to
be fair we shouldn't go too hard on Baro
Works members I mean she did have her
hair in a ponytail when she was Miss
Wednesday so maybe they just failed to
make the connection during the wano AR
the garos revealed that the real name of
Luffy's devil fruit is hito honomi model
naika and that it is one of the devil
fruits they fear the most so my question
is why didn't they get rid of Luffy
earlier before he had a chance to awaken
it and that's not all let's not forget
that Luffy's first Bounty had the name
monkey Duffy on it given the fact that
members of Declan are always the ones
who cause problems for the world
government doesn't it just make sense to
capture them while they are still weak
and inexperienced and if you still think
that's not a good enough reason in his
Bounty photo Luffy also wears Roger's
legendary straw hat which emu must have
noticed immediately now to be fair they
did send some people after Luffy but it
never seemed as if they were taking it
seriously it was like Luffy was just
another random pirate to them which we
now know is far from the truth however
considering how Sabu managed to escape
the room while G Ro and emu were around
it seems that these guys might not be
the brightest although there are some
ways you could try to justify World
government's actions this next plot hole
about Sanji just straight up doesn't
make any sense you see during sanji's
fight against absolum back in Thriller
bark we learned that Sanji used to be a
massive devil fruit nerd he even read
the entire devil fruit encyclopedia but
for some reason during barati arc when
Luffy fell into the sea he didn't pull
him out it wasn't until zeff told him
about the devil fruit's weakness that he
jumped to save Luffy You could argue
that Sanji didn't remember this fact
about devil fruits but he sure as hell
knew what he was talking about during
Thriller bark although this is a pretty
big plot hole it's nothing compared to
the last one on this list and while we
are on the topic of Thriller bark do you
remember how most of the zombies there
were bandaged this was because Hogback
was conducting some serious experiments
on them like taking them apart and
putting them back together however for
some reason when morya spawned his
zombies during the Marine Ford War they
were also bandaged which shouldn't be
the case as Hogback never experimented
on them it's possible that Oda just lik
the way they looked with bandages and
decided to keep them that way even
though it doesn't make sense okay let's
now talk about hockey and what the hell
happened to it during pre-time skip
ideally we should have learned about
hockey in zoro's fight against mihawk or
maybe heard about it from zeth but we
didn't Luffy then fought against one of
the seven Warlords crocodile and somehow
hockey was never mentioned during that
battle even during the en's lobby when
the straw hats spot against cp9 we still
didn't learn about it you could say that
pre- time skip villains were pretty weak
and that's why they didn't know hockey
but what about Blackbeard versus Ace
then surely these two used hockey during
their battle nope still nothing it
wasn't until saow Arc that we finally
got to St hockey consistently with rley
and Luffy using it although you could
come up with many explanations as to why
this is the case it's most likely that
Oda didn't plan to include hockey when
he initially started the series and
that's why the pre-time skip seems a bit
off sometimes another thing during
pre-time skip that doesn't add up happen
during episode 314 when we were
introduced to the four Emperors for the
first time if you look at this picture
there seems to be something wrong with
kaido he looks nothing like himself he
looks more like an evil Mage with a wide
face and a beak-like nose even hundreds
of episodes later during episode 570
kaido's silhouette still looks
completely different it wasn't until
chapter 693 was released least that
kaido started looking more like himself
and later his design was set in stone
during his first appearance so what
exactly happened here well although it's
not technically a plot hole Odum most
likely had second thoughts on kaido's
initial design and wanted to change it
and since these two scenes are almost a
decade apart it didn't impact the story
in any meaningful way which can't really
be said for this next one so in the show
it was explained that the world
government erased all information about
Rox D zc but don't you still find it a
bit weird how no one has ever mentioned
the the guy before I mean even Luffy
still hasn't heard about him Rox was the
captain of the most dangerous pirate
crew as well as Captain of three former
Emperors everyone in the world must have
known who he was so why does no one talk
about him we know the world government
didn't literally erase him from
everyone's memories because kaido and
mini Marines still remember him really
well I know Oda is making him out to be
all mysterious but still the one piece
World should be more realistic than this
only four more plot holes are left to
cover and let's talk about Sky Island
next next Luffy and Zoro were absolutely
humiliated for even thinking that Sky
Island exists they were literally beaten
up and laughed out of the bar but as it
turned out the sky island actually does
exist as the story progressed and we
were introduced to more characters it
seemed like everyone went to the sky
island even if we don't count the top
tiers like Roger and kaido urug gay was
seen praying on the sky island and even
good old Bellamy found his way up there
despite everyone making the sky island
seem like something super mysterious
it's not not it was even stated that
there's a much safer way to get there
somewhere in the new world so it really
doesn't make sense how more people
didn't at least hear about it well since
we gotten this far how about we discuss
Chopper's ridiculously low Bounty next I
know his Bounty is used as comic relief
but after all this time shouldn't the
world government have realized that
Chopper is more than just a pet you
could say that the world government
never seen Chopper's real strength but
that's not really true for example
during the en's lobby Arc Chopper
defeated kumadori a cp9 agent working
directly for the government this alone
should earn him a sizable Bounty I'm not
going to spend more time talking about
it since it's obviously just a gag but
come on give the little guy the proper
Bounty he deserves before we cover the
biggest plot hole in the entire one
piece let's quickly cover this one that
I'm sure none of you noticed in chapter
605 the monster Trio is equipped with
swim coating which was supposed to allow
them to breathe underwater kind of like
a diving suit there is limited air
inside these bubbles so it is to be used
wisely however Luffy immed immediately
ignores the science and somehow uses
Gear 3 while inside the bubble this
obviously shouldn't be possible as
there's no additional hair for Luffy to
use what's even funnier is that only a
few panels before Frankie refrained from
using cou to burst because their bubble
Air Supply was limited I guess the same
exact logic doesn't apply to Luffy devil
fruits are pretty straightforward you
eat them gain some absurd ability and
you cannot be in the water for the rest
of your life however there have been a
few characters in the show who
completely defied this Logic for example
when boa was taking a bath she wasn't
feeling weak it was a calm and relaxing
experience for her this is a bit weird
because in reality she should look
something more like Luffy in this photo
when he tried to take a bath but let's
forget about boa for now what the hell
happened to Mr 3 on this panel you can
clearly see that he is knocked out but
is somehow floating on water instead of
drowning however the funniest mistake
has to be this one in episode 989 when
kinamon literally hides underwater to be
fair this is not mistake as this
specific scene doesn't exist in the
manga but still you have to admit that
it looks pretty funny click on this
video where we covered six mindblowing
one piece
theories